What does massage do anyway, and are there
health benefits besides feeling really, really
good?
Hey guys, Crystal here with DNews.
I grew up a dancer and a gymnast, and therapeutic
massage was just a part of my athletic life.
Even now after a tough week at the gym or
too much time spent on airplanes I turn to
a masseur to work things out.
Its no secret that massages make us feel good
and this fact has even been verified by science!
In one of my favorite mouse studies ever,
Caltech researchers identified a specific
set of sensory neurons common among mammals
that trigger pleasurable responses when activated
by a firm stroking sensation.
Yes, some researcher massaged a bunch of mice
and then wrote a paper on it, because science
is awesome.
But is massage actually helping to improve
muscle function and recovery after a hard
workout?
What are muscle “knots”?, and what about
those “toxins” that my masseur keeps talking
about?
A study by researchers at McMaster University
studied the biological changes in the muscles
of 11 young men after they pushed themselves
to exhaustion with exercise.
Using biopsy of leg muscle tissue, the researchers
were able to show that a 10 minute post-workout
massage can reduce cellular stress and inflammation
in response to mechanical injury, increase
mitochondrial production leading to improved
muscle repair and function, and reduce pain!
Notably absent in the study was any evidence
that massage could help clear lactic acid
from tired muscles or improve glycogen levels.
Two benefits commonly associated with the
practice, So please, continue to drink water
after your workout and massage to keep your
body hydrated, but “flushing out the released
toxins” isn’t really a thing.
The scientific literature is less clear when
it comes to defining just what is going on
when your muscle contracts into painful knots
or why massage seems to help.
In fact there was very little in the way of
convincing literature out there on the subject,
but the most compelling argument I found proposed
that a “muscle knot is your muscle remaining
flexed and refusing to relax,” and the result
of inflammation due to the release of lactic
acid.
In this case massage of the affected area
would help reduce the inflammation and allow
the muscle to relax, similar to the ameliorating
effect of NonSteroidal Anti Inflammatory Drugs
like ibuprofen.
But obviously more research is needed before
we can say we know for sure.
So massage does actually help your muscles
heal and recover, and that positive affect
is from more than just physical manipulation
of your muscle tissue!
It actually increases activation of biochemical
pathways that respond to mechanical stress
and suppresses immune responses that lead
to inflammation.
Pretty cool.
Im totally going to use this new information
to justify more frequent massage appointments.
Speaking of reducing pain, have you ever wondered
what the difference is between some of the
most well-known over-the-counter pain relievers?
Julia explores that topic in this video